we turn now to a difficult subject for
many families how to tackle cyber
bullying new research study from Pew
finds nearly half of teens in the USA
they have been bullied or harassed
online it can take many forms including
physical threats the spreading of false
rumors and receiving unsolicited
explicit images Jamie Howard is a senior
clinical psychologist from the child
MIND Institute and she's here with us in
studio to discuss good morning good to
see you good morning so Jamie I know
that um when I think about the online
bullying that teens go through today I
was bullied as a child and the the
Saving Grace was I could leave school
and I could go to the safety and comfort
of my home but this online Bullying
happens 24 hours a day for children who
are targeted and most parents don't know
that their kids are being bullied
because they're not very connected to
their kids social media networks that's
right so what to do so I always
recommend that parents stay connected to
their kids and to their social media so
when they start out around age 13 I say
to parents install parental monitoring
software and tell your kids that you're
doing that because you want to make sure
that they learn how to be kind
respectful and really understand that
the digital footprint is permanent it
could always be found and it could
affect them later in life and so you
want to monitor them to make sure that
they are behaving appropriately and then
you can give them the the freedom that
they want after a trial period parental
monitoring software what exactly does it
allow parents to do it feels a little
big brother it is that's why I say tell
your kids we don't want this to be
secretly you're going into your kid's
bedroom and reading their journal
without their consent but this is about
establishing good practices and so what
parents can do is on their own device
they can see everything that their kids
are up to they can see what they're
posting and what they're receiving and
then there's so much more equipped to
intervene if something happens if
someone says something inappropriate and
they can guide them and how to respond
you know each type of trauma deserves
its own individual respect and Vlad you
alluded to it um those that might be
being bullied in person are dealing with
trauma but you're also dealing with
trauma if you're being bullied online I
want to speak from the perspective of
some parents and maybe you've heard this
before where they say well if my kid's
getting bullied online I'ma tell them to
get offline I'm telling them to put down
the phone they don't have to get bullied
they can they can run away from their TV
or tablet or phone what do you say to
parents that think that way
unfortunately that won't really work
because the bullying can still happen
it's just that your child isn't exactly
reading it and hearing about it in real
time but they're going to hear about it
and know about it in other ways and we
know that rates of depression and
anxiety are are increasing for kids at
this age and suicide's a leading cause
of death and unfortunately the cat's out
of the box and we can't tell kids you
may not have social media or they'll
suffer socially and then here at third
hand which is even worse sometimes right
so when should parents intervene because
some parents may think you know this
might be an important experience for my
child to learn how to be resilient
through this but at this same time you
want to protect your kid yeah there's
severity there's a there's degrees of
severity right so if explicit images are
being sent of your child that's actually
illegal and that you want to go to the
authorities for something like that if
someone is calling your child a mean
name maybe that's something that you can
teach them how to hold their head high
and really connect with their allies
their good friends spend a little more
time with good friends in real life and
sometimes you want to go to other
parents teenagers don't always love this
they usually hate this and yet still the
stakes are high right with depression
and anxiety On The Rise so here's a
question
um what if your child is the bully right
so kids make mistakes right like the the
base rate of of being a sociopath is
very low so chances are that this is a
good kid who's making a mistake who
doesn't have sufficient guidance and so
this is an opportunity for you to say
Okay I I got to take a step back and
teach my child really explicitly what I
expect from him or her we know from a
study at the Harvard school that parents
tend to communicate to kids that their
happiness and achievement matters more
to them as parents than their kindness
and we have to flip that and say it
matters to me that you're kind and
respectful thank you so much Jamie
Howard for being here